welcome to this video playing our lip
from Turkey Turkish like at least so
let's get going never played this guy
okay come on let's do something a little
bit different okay it's completely
unfazed just g3 immediately k where
transposing to go go anyway check yeah
that's an old line here in the bogo
indian not a super dangerous one for
black but still of course very solid
from White's perspective
now III it begs a little bit difficult
for black you to determine the pawn
structure there I can play you for but
this is kind of its weakening a little
bit and has to be considered quite
carefully if I want to play it for and
while taking on default doesn't make
much sense in most cases yeah I just
want to stay solid yes going for before
yeah why not
hmm that's that's all very true ok let's
try to regroup okay and those nights
look funky right ok it's just playing
instant moves all the time ok I
understand that I didn't play it well
but is it so terrible ok so 96 or
something let's protect a little bit
down hmm yeah I don't know this so bad
this pawn on d6 is not necessarily a
strength can also get a bit weak
my g5 okay don't quite okay he wants to
play Queen 87 yep that much I hit that
much I understand but bad to trade them
I don't know
I 26 or to see 5 mm okay
not much fun it really isn't
ok you might trade and play with 27 then
huh ok that's not good this 97 is not a
big problem ugly but necessary ok so
let's see if i can trade that ok and
probably SEL
then we hope that I have is of course
that is playing without his King so
maybe I have some opportunities to get
the pawn them my king is is starting to
help with King e7 like 95 d7 trying to
get the pawn maybe
tempo
97 and what then is going rooks is six
okay i can at least play 95 them and
draw 98 this rook c7 so let's let's do
this and then think if i can try to
avoid the draw somehow it's not easy not
easy to avoid g6 is hanging that that's
quite quite a problem
maybe he wants to try to win this well I
didn't know sometimes yeah he wants to
not sure that this is just a fright dome
okay how do I get get the pawn down not
925 difficult trying to get it to a
forum
okay time warning
takes cheeks king of six John came after
after all of that we just tell Jack draw
an ending
how interesting he tries to play for
wind down but I have some tricks as well
check
check
well
talk talk about a tough end game with
absolutely no time down check check
check check that's some way to do
something here probably not I still
think if anybody can play for that's
probably him Wow and I'm winning that's
a miracle check white forfeits on time
wow wow now the only way to try to win
this was to let him play for win and it
was I was probably lost at some points
here this this was interesting yeah I
completely I did not see that it would
probably been a bit easier check the
probability of a draw is still very high
though it was cool yeah I have this fork
tricks here I don't know as I think this
is a drop probably this is some kind of
positional draw we gave cash checks chat
whatnot check then you was check
finally grabbing their on g7 check
that's probably still a draw somehow but
how computer okay the computers is
giving the answer look age seven that's
that's good that's that's a very good
way to draw now I cannot take and here
he is getting getting the pawn down yeah
but he should he should ready okay he he
sim simply blundered there with no time
on the clock and all of a sudden I was
winning very lucky winning okay well
thanks for watching